mozi nation what it do the number one
question that i continue to get on
instagram and on this channel is what
are the habits that created some of the
success we have and so in this video i
want to walk you through the four
highest roi habits uh that have viewed
outsized returns if you don't know who i
am or have him into this channel my name
is alex ramose i own acquisition.com we
do about 85 million a year it's a
portfolio company and i have nothing to
sell you the reason i make this channel
is because a lot of people are broke and
i don't want you to be one of them and
of the videos that i've made this one is
actually from the past i had a private
community that i um used to just put
videos in for fun over the last five
years over 300 of them and this video
was one of the top one person videos and
so i wanted to share with you guys
publicly enjoy
good morning everyone hope you guys are
having a fantastic amazing tremendous
thursday i wanted to make a quick uh
video for you i actually woke up with
this on my mind and i thought i would
share it and so i'm calling this my four
highest roi habits and i know i probably
should say three because three is
probably a better number before was what
i was really thinking about these are
the things that were learned behaviors
that i think if i look back on behaviors
that have been able that have propelled
us forward faster
these are the four things that have
done that the first one is waking up at
4 00 a.m
and it kind of goes hand in hand with
the second habits i'll kind of put these
together which is consistent bedtimes
and that includes weekends so basically
consistent time going to bed and
consistent time waking up and i know
that sounds minor but a lot of times and
for a long period of my life i would
wake up early five days a week and then
on weekends i would sleep in and i'd go
to bed late because i was like i'm
living on the weekends and during the
week i'm working and i did that for a
long period of time the thing is is like
your body doesn't work that way i think
there's the consistency in the most
basic way is literally going to bed at
the same time weekend and weekday and
waking up at the same time week and and
weekday i know this sounds really minor
but like especially that 4 a.m wake up
time like us as entrepreneurs like we're
i think we're a little bit more reactive
than most people are from an emotional
standpoint uh like i think we're also a
little bit more scattered by nature i
don't like to speak that over myself but
i think that that's like our intrinsic
programming and then we can work away
from that that's why control i talk so
much about controlling your space
controlling your attention is that like
we're so much more
prone to reactivity um which is also why
we want to solve problems faster because
we're more uncomfortable than any of
everyone else's which is why we
naturally move towards problem solving
right
and so waking up at 4am allows me to get
all of my self-work done in the morning
and still have two three four five
sometimes dedicated hours
to moving the big dominoes forward the
big projects that are going to make
massive impact in the business and are
working on the business not in it
basically once i hit you know 9 00 a.m
9 30 a.m i would love to tell you
that like oh i have i have four hours of
ceo time in the middle of the day that
everyone knows that i can't be reached
the problem is that like
you know if you have a lawyer call come
in because we have some you know
thing or whatever like i'm gonna take
the call if we have a personnel issue
where someone's like going nuts you know
what i mean like i'm going to take the
call
and so like it's it sure would sound
nice to say like yeah i mean we're so
disciplined at jim lunch that alex never
gets you know brought in anything and to
be fair the team is awesome and like i
really don't get brought into a lot of
stuff but the thing is it's like my
attention still gets pulled during the
day um once everyone else is kind of up
but from like four o'clock to nine
o'clock is like my time and that's where
i really move like all of these big
projects forward and that's why i like
like how you get so much done so fast is
like i just think most people don't get
very much done during their days at all
um because they're working in their
business not on it and so we just move
we just
are able to do a lot of things on the
business which then accelerates the
entire growth of the business because
these are like like the the bricks that
you lay on the business are the ones
that accelerate growth the things you do
in the business is kind of like one is
investment one is
uh what is spending cash you know what i
mean like an expense of time is how
you're running your business an
investment of time is what's going to
move the entire business forward and so
it's like are you are you putting
investment time in and so for me 4 am to
like nine is like that time period the
two first success like i'm gonna say
success habits because that sounds lame
but like basically the habits that have
gotten me that have made me the most
money waking up at 4 a.m and that is
enabled by
uh going to bed consistently at the same
time on weekdays and weekends it's just
like you can't wake up at nine two days
a week and then wake up five hours
earlier and expect to be like a
productive individual it's just not
gonna happen
so like i would implore you to just like
i mean and we're like what about like
concerts and like things that are like
it's going out with people like
there's a reason entrepreneurs live the
way they do like really high-level
entrepreneurs
live a certain way and it is a sacrifice
i mean if you see it that way it is a
choice
and so like i choose
that life and that's the life that i
choose you don't have to choose that
just understand like you're going to
like that's your trade-off like and for
me
going out to dinner
at 7 30 on friday is not important to me
um i'd rather go like all of my friends
who are here in austin
know that like if they're gonna go out
with alex and layla we're going to
dinner at 5 45 so that we like get there
we're seated we get certain like we're
eating by 6 15 and we can leave by seven
drive home by 7 30 and then we can wind
down right like they know that going
into it it's just like if you don't want
to play that then like that's cool and
it means that like our relationship
isn't valuable enough for you to eat
dinner earlier and that's fine you know
what i mean most people are game to do
that and they're like you know it's so
nice being able to get back at eight and
like not ruin your routine i'm like yeah
it's awesome like that's why we do it so
uh first two waking up early and then
consistent bedtimes uh on the weekends
especially the next one is
this is a little bit different this is
something that layla has told me has
been like one of the things that she
observed early on in our relationship
before she like knew me as her husband
but like just the guy that she thought
was
doing things i jin this man it sounds
kind of weird saying it but like this
was her observation that she thought i
should bring up in this was that like
genuinely trying to give
to other people
in your network without expectation i've
always been voted like into like
president and leadership positions and
like every organized like when i was in
high school i was a newspaper and
president of the um literary magazine uh
when i went to college i was president
uh you know vp of the powerlifting team
and president of the
uh of the fraternity i was in like it's
like you know me like continues on and
the thing is like most people think
about leadership is that like i have to
be the big boss man it doesn't work that
way for those who ever studied it it's
like the people who get voted into power
are the people that that uh like
it's funny people always think like the
president fraternity is the one that's
like the biggest rager but the person
that they want to vote into president is
the one who's going to take the punch
ball away to make sure that like when
the party is getting going to make sure
that like we don't get arrested and like
you know things happen the way they're
supposed to and it's and it comes from a
place of service like cern it's
literally just giving without
expectation um and that comes to clients
and a lot of times like i would say some
of the highest roi
givings that i've done have been to
people in my network where they're like
hey man do you know anything about this
and then i will go the extra mile
to
connect them with not one person but
like four people do some initial
screening myself and say hey man like
this is what i saw this is what it looks
like here's two people that i think
might be able to help you and then this
is my experience with it and they're
like holy [ __ ] like thank you that's
like awesome and then what happens is
like you actually form a much better
relationship because they're like wow
this person like really cared right and
then also in the future if i say like
hey man do you know anything about this
then they return the favor right and so
um layla jokes about she's like you have
so many favors that you like
have uncalled upon like so many ious
just like i feel like whenever we need
something like you like you have three
people you can call who immediately jump
to help you and the only reason that
happens is because i jump to help them
with nothing like ex like expecting
nothing back but just because i know
that like long term they may have
something or know someone who and it's
not because of that it's just like and
that's why it's like sort of a nature
nurture you know whatever but i can tell
you like if you can help people you will
get more back and your reputation will
also follow from that so those are
probably the three biggest uh roi habits
uh the fourth one
is what likely leila said that i should
i should mention uh well she's like you
should say something about sales i joked
back where i was like i think that's
more of a skill set and not not not a
habit not a behavior if there were to be
a habit that would be associated with
that it's jumping into a skill that you
are not good at with the expectation
that my first 20 hours i expect zero
return on
and so like if you can look at new
skills that you are not good at or do
not like we always have this discomfort
without acquiring new skills uh like
let's say i don't know how to run
facebook ads i don't know how to make a
landing page i don't know how to manage
a team whatever it is right like you're
going to suck for a while i think if you
can remove the emotional blockage that
stops you from taking action because
most of us don't like start that new
thing because we're afraid of sucking
like just being real like we're
emotionally afraid of sucking at it and
so if you think to yourself i'm gonna
get zero roi for my first 20 hours
ironically the first 20 hours is where
you get like 70 of your gains
in any new skill and then like
everything after like hour number 20 is
like
massive diminishing returns that happens
after that right and so like if you just
jump into it with zero expectations for
first 20 hours you'd be amazed at like
like how many people here if they
actually tried like those who are on
here were like man i really need to
learn how to market if you google how to
run a facebook ad
and you spend 20 hours watching videos
on how to do it you will be better than
99
of people who try and market
because no one does anything like
seriously like no one does anything and
like most people suck at most things
including the things they think they're
good at right and those ones they
ultimately usually aren't that good at
either
it's because they're pride because they
associate the fact that they're good at
it uh and then they stop learning
because they think they are good because
of their ego and so um that's actually
what the fourth one was going to be i
was like i know she said sales so i
think that the fourth the fourth habit
is absolute um responsibility for all
situations it's absolute ownership of
your life um if anything happens at any
time in my relationship with layla with
my relationship with an employee with my
relationship with the marketplace
whatever it is you have to school
yourself and literally beat the victim
out of yourself like you have to like
you have to drag it and beat the crap
out of it until it has no strength in
your life saying like i'm going to blame
my circumstances i'm going to blame my
past i'm going to blame my upbringing
i'm going to blame my spouse i'm going
to blame my employees whatever it is
it does not move you forward if you
point the finger anywhere but yourself
because then it literally gives the
power away
to the to where you're pointing your
finger you're saying i want the power to
be away from me
like i want the power to be away from me
and then i'm talking to my clients too
like if you ever blame jim lunch and
like i will take complete and extreme
ownership over all of your situations
because that is my job but if you want
to grow as an entrepreneur you should
take extreme ownership and and put
nothing on our business and i'm talking
to you like person to person right like
i will always try and over deliver
always but the point is is like if we're
talking about like my four highest roi
habits first one is waking up super
early so that i can have time to
dedicate to big dominoes the second one
is so that i can have consistency in my
life and weekdays and weekends are the
same to me so waking up and going to bed
at the same time so that i have
consistency in the most basic way the
third i totally forgot
uh what it was but it was i think it was
good and then the fourth is uh absolute
oh yeah uh giving first without any any
uh feelings of reciprocity and then the
fourth is absolute ownership and i think
that of all the habits that i've had to
learn in my life because each one of
those was learned like i was not
an early riser um i did for a very long
time like having different weekend
schedules than weekday schedules from
like a sleeping standpoint etc to be
fair of all of these i think the one
that i that that came most nationally to
me was the third one which is giving
first um and i think that company
honestly from a place of insecurity is
like i wanted everyone to like me and so
like if i get into a new group a new
networking group like i spend a lot of
time typically
asking people what they're struggling
with and like what skills i have that
match up with their deficits and then
doing everything i can to over deliver
to them and like like treat them as
though they paid me um to help them and
then they're like dude this guy's
amazing um and and then i feel like my
anxiety goes down inside of a network
group so that might just be a me thing
but it has been something that has um
i've been able to drive a lot of value
from a monetary standpoint later on in
my life by being able to call
on people who i had to unfavor stupid
paths
and then the fourth is
literally never giving anyone power over
your situation
by saying it's anyone's fault but your
own and um i will leave with i've said
this before but one of my favorite
quotes is that
we are all self-made only millionaires
and billionaires
uh own it and so uh like
everyone's like he's a self-made
millionaire is a self-made billionaire
it's like that person is a self-made
homeless person that person's a
self-made
average person like but they don't own
that and there's a reason for it no one
says it because the type of person who's
going to say that they're self-made is
going to have the habits and the
outlooks that is going to achieve the
things that they want and so um i will
leave you with that
as my four highest roi habits
if you have a manager or
trainer or a partner or whatever
i would highly highly recommend
especially the first two they're the
easiest things in the world to do get
your bio clock like regular like you
show up as a leader better you have more
energy you have more focus people like
you get so much stuff done it's like
because i'm not [ __ ] exhausted all
the time but like excuse me like i'm
just not tired you know what i mean and
so i can like work and get things done
that are productive and effective uses
of time because i'm just not exhausted
and so like
imagine if you like felt good all the
time like you can do that it just comes
from consistently going to bed at the
same time
dr cashy i'll say one more thing dr
cashy um jokes that so he's a
my phd buddy who made all prestige labs
and
is a nutrition genius phd by 21 in
biochemistry blah blah anyways he's like
people just people just
pay me to tell them to do things that
they should already know how to do he's
like i tell them to not eat like an
[ __ ] and i tell them to act like an
adult
and go to bed on time they're like man
like how do i how do i have more energy
i've got all like i've i've taken all
these stimulants and they're not working
he's like
why don't you try sleeping and then
people sleep and then they get like
they're like oh my god this changed my
life i was like yeah like amazing it's
like so i tell them to like eat
consistently every day the same thing
just eat consistently i don't even tell
them what to eat and then all of a
sudden they start getting healthy
because they're just consistent with
something right it doesn't matter what
you're consistent with half the time
being consistent is in and of itself
something that most humans can't do so
um i hope uh this provided value to you
i said this on my instagram post today i
kind of like it um may your desire be
greater than your obstacles so lots of
love everyone hope you guys have an
amazing day and you crush your goals uh
try out some of those uh habits try out
some of those sevens i think that they
are very high roi habits and i think
that if you do them um your life will
improve so have an amazing day catch you
soon